Prof: Last time we got
into Canto X and I began with
the Heaven of the Sun,
and I began with the
description of--
Dante begins,
we went over the phases of the
canto.
On the one hand the description
of the Trinity of the inner life
of the Trinity as a life of
love,
the breath and the father--
love, the sun,
the father bound by the breath
of love as it were.
Then Dante moves onto a
description of the spectacle of
the whole--
this heaven and of this
fragment of the cosmos by
turning to us readers twice,
asking us to look up.
It is that by looking up we can
see the givenness of creation,
the fact that this has been
given;
it's a gift to us.
It's also a way of--if it's a
gift,
if there's an economy,
a feel economy in the cosmos,
it's a divine economy,
it also means that somehow we
cannot really claim to own it.
That seems to be a natural
consequence of something being a
gift does not imply,
does not entail necessarily
ownership of this gift;
it has been given and therefore
we are invited to have an
aesthetic admiration of it.
This kind of--this scene of the
divine,
even a kind of feel drama,
a divine drama,
a spectacle that unfolds
ends--folds throughout the
cosmos,
ends with a description of the
encyclopedia as I was describing
it to you.
That is to say with Aquinas who
recounts the names and mentions
one after the other,
the twelve representatives of
various disciplines.
We talked a little bit about
Solomon and the scandal that his
inclusion here caused in Dante's
own time,
since Dante is responding to a
real crisis about unknowledge of
the ultimate fate of Solomon,
the wisest of all men.
Was he saved or not on account
of his weaknesses in terms of
his, well his lechery?
Then the canto focuses on--ends
really with Siger of Brabant who
was a logician,
a philosopher and Dante
describes him really on the way
to knowledge.
He was a heretic,
he was viewed of as a heretic.
Dante dismisses that whole
charge, and in many ways he
represents therefore knowledge
as--
or the circle of knowledge as
one made of contradictory
voices,
where those who had been
blaming Siger of Brabant,
such as Aquinas himself,
now retract their positions;
so the whole process of getting
to know the world is one of
errors and it's one of
retractions.
There are some interesting
details that I could even--I
think that I should even mention
to you as we approach XI and
XII.
Siger is described as he's
absorbed in his grave thoughts.
In Italian it is gravi
pensieri,
the word pensiero is,
in English, is pensive.
I think that that is such a
remarkable word because it
really means "to
think" in Latin,
and they always exploit this
resonance of the verb--
means to be at an impasse,
to be suspended literally,
so he's suspended in thoughts
as if the thoughts could not
quite make him reach the
threshold of the knowledge he
wanted.
At any rate,
that's the way Canto X--that's
the economy of Canto X.
I want to--since there are
three cantos that go together to
really--
I ask you to turn to the end of
Canto XII where Bonaventure,
who is a Franciscan,
you probably know what is meant
by that.
The Franciscan is one of the
orders of Francis,
just as Aquinas is Dominican.
The Franciscans are those who
believe in the priority of will
and love in the act of
knowledge.
The Dominicans or
neo-Aristotelians like Aquinas
believe in the priority of the
intellect in the apprehension of
the world.
The Dominicans were founded
with the explicit mandate to
teach in the universities where
heresies they thought abounded
and therefore they had to
extirpate,
block off the routes of
heresies.
The Franciscans were going to
be witnessing in the world,
and both orders are shaped by a
belief in poverty that we have
to examine a little bit.
We have to understand what it
means.
At any rate,
Bonaventure is a Franciscan and
by the end of Canto XII,
after he has been chronicling
the life of Dominic.
This is sort of another case of
extraordinary openness of,
in Dante's view,
of these characters in the
sense that the Franciscans and
Dominicans were really at odds
with each other,
both in terms of their
theologies and their premises,
intellectual premises above all.
Here, Dante has a Franciscan
tell the life of Dominic just as
earlier in Canto XI a Dominican,
Aquinas, tells the life of
Francis.
The two cantos are controlled
by what we call a chiasmus
that's--
this is a chiasmus from the
Greek word "chi,"
a chiasmus, right?
You have an intersection of
voices, a sort of--a sense of
the interdependence of the two
perspectives.
I will say a little bit more
about Bonaventure after I read
this paragraph.
This paragraph here,
the last paragraph in Canto
XII,
lines 130 and following,
sort of functions as a
counterweight to the description
of the encyclopedia that Aquinas
had given at the end of Canto X
and ending with Siger of Brabant
so let me just see who the
people are here.
"I am the living soul of
Bonaventura of Bagnorea,
who in great offices ever put
last the left-hand care.
Here are Illuminato and
Augustine, who were among the
first barefoot Poor Brothers
that in the cord made themselves
God's friends."
Then a theorist of medieval
encyclopedias,
Hugh of St.
Victor, a Parisian friar who
really wrote the so called
Didascalicon,
which is a text about what
is--what are the stages of
education?
How does the mind come to the
knowledge of God starting from
the small elements in the
outside life,
the material world,
then the interior lights,
etc., before reaching
the--God's supreme light?
Then is here with them Peter
the bookworm,
Peter the Spaniard,
another theorist of medieval
logic who shines below in twelve
books,
then Nathan the prophet--I'll
come back to this name,
the prophet Nathan.
He is known,
to those who know,
as being David's bad
conscience, or good conscience,
the one who is pricking him to
think about himself.
Nathan, the prophet sensor
counselor of the King,
a little bit more about him in
a while and Chrysostom,
the Metropolitan,
meaning that guy with the
golden mouth.
Language here is the flower of
eloquence is what he possesses.
And Anselm, another theologian
who writes about the reasons for
the incarnations,
famous texts about why did God
become a man and then Donatus
"who deigned to set his
hand to the first art;
grammar.
So you see you have the whole
array, the whole wide spectrum
of what we call the
encyclopedia.
Logic, eloquence,
grammar, Donatus is a Roman
grammarian,
and then Rabanus a historian,
"and beside me shines the
Calabrian Abbot Joachim,
who was endowed with a spirit
of prophecy.
The glowing courtesy and
well-judged language of Brother
Thomas have moved me to
celebrate so great a paladin,
and with me have moved this
company."
Bonaventure ends with the tip
of the hat in the direction of
Aquinas whose example he has
followed.
An example, once again,
of a dialogue and openness
between the two orders and the
two members of different orders
and yet--
and somehow interdependent with
each other.
Now the presence of Abbot
Joachim is another counterweight
to Siger of Brabant in Canto X.
He too, Joachim,
whom you have met because I
sort of mentioned his name to
you in discussing the prophecy--
glossing the prophecy of the
DXV in Purgatorio XXXIII.
You remember where I tried to
explain it;
there seems to be a kind of
apocalyptic meaning to that
prophecy,
the numerical enigma,
an enigmatic prophecy about the
coming of Christ at the end of
time,
who will come and therefore the
prophecy of the consummation of
history,
and the consummation of time,
the DXV,
the 500,10, and 5 as that is
called.
And I said that the joachistic
interpretation of that emblem,
of that symbol seemed to me to
be accurate.
I really meant,
it really sort of introduces
the idea of the end of time,
however, I rejected--I asked
you to also reject the
implications of that prophecy.
The joachistic prophecy--it was
viewed as heretical for a number
of important reasons.
It expresses a sort of
impatience about history.
That is to say it really
believes, first of all,
in the imminent and closure of
history,
the end is close at hand,
and this is a kind of--
the end of history implies the
coming into being of a utopia,
a utopia of the spirit,
the third age of the spirit,
when finally all institutions,
all barriers are shattered and
torn down.
This is a kind of--this is
really what--from Dante's point
of view would be wrong with a
joachistic utopian impulse.
The idea that it always begs
for a closure of what we can
never really fathom,
which is the world of
historical occurrences,
but another reason why he was
viewed as heretical by exactly
Bonaventure,
it was Bonaventure who asked
that his views be damned and now
he is sort of writing a
palinode.
Dante allows him to make amends
for the previous condemnation.
Bonaventure found objectionable
the ideas of Joachim of Flora
because Joachim de facto is
dissolving the whole notion of
the unity of the Trinitarian
life.
He theorizes an idea of
history, a tripartite idea of
history according to the three
persons of the Trinity:
the age of the Father,
the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
He believes there was once,
in biblical times,
there was the age of the
Father, God was understood as
the Father.
Then we enter the age of the
Son, brotherhoods of all,
and now the spiritual age of
the Holy Spirit.
De facto really means that the
three ways--
the three manifestations,
this kind of complex way of
understanding a unity from
different viewpoints is actually
dissolved.
It becomes separate,
each person of the Trinity
becomes a separate entity,
and that view from--for
Bonaventure was heretical,
he condemns it,
now he acknowledges that he
actually was Abbot Joachim who
was endowed with a spiritual
prophecy.
It is something only prophetic,
in other words,
what seemed to here heresy,
an intellectual question of
thoughts and opinions now
appears as some divination about
things to come,
not specified any further.
Retrospectively,
it's Dante himself who is
legitimizing Joachim and
therefore also legitimizing his
own position in Canto XXXIII of
Purgatorio.
Dante shares the view of the
apocalyptic denuma of history,
however, he refuses,
he rejects the idea that it's
possible to establish a date for
such an occurrence.
Joachim appears now as a
visionary among them.
The other figure that I would
like to say something about is
Nathan the prophet for a very
simple reason,
because Nathan as you probably
know--
because it's very strange,
why would Dante include Nathan
a prophet among--
there's Joachim of Flora who is
prophetic,
but why include Nathan among
these wise spirits?
I mean, he could have chosen so
many others.
He could have chosen those who
actually have written and whose
works are canonical in the
Bible.
He doesn't.
He chooses Nathan and the idea
is, I think,
a little bit of an
autobiographical,
a pun about Dante himself,
because Nathan,
the word Nathan means "he
who gives."
In other words,
Dante saw in the name of Nathan
his own name,
and it pleases him,
that's what Dante means,
he who gives.
Nathan becomes a kind of mask
for Dante himself.
It is as if he were saying,
had I another life or a
posthumous life in the heavenly
apotheosis that's where I
probably would like--
that's where I probably will
end up,
certainly that's what I would
like to be,
so in Nathan there is a mask
for himself.
Now why--what is this so
peculiar about this encyclopedic
ordering of the arts and the
sciences?
It doesn't really differ very
much from Aquinas,
but it's interesting that it's
Bonaventure who articulates,
who voices this kind of--who
celebrates all these names and
all these arts because
Bonaventure is himself a
theorist of the encyclopedia
very much as Hugh of St.
Victor, but he has one crucial
reflection at the beginning of
his encyclopedia.
He says that the activity of
knowing and learning is like
going up and down a ladder.
You might say,
if you read that metaphor,
you might say well that's an
extraordinary metaphor but it's
the metaphor of the ladder of
Jacob in the Bible,
which is where he probably
found it.
The ladder of Plato,
that's where this idea that we
ascend,
the mind ascends when we learn
something,
when we get educated the mind
goes up and it actually can go
down.
The interesting thing about
Bonaventure is that he goes on
saying that as in a ladder the
lowest rung are always more
important than the higher ones,
because without those no one of
us would be capable to climb up
the ladder,
so the lowest,
the lowly forms of knowledge,
grammar--the external lights of
the senses you see
distinguishes--
his is a theory of knowledge as
a proliferation of lights,
as a universe of lights,
internal, external lights,
internal lights,
the lights of the senses,
the lights that come to us from
books and the light of God and
so on.
So we are always going to be
enlightened in our process,
but as we are enlightened the
lowest lights are,
first of all,
self-sufficient.
There are those who may not be
capable of ascending much higher
in the--along the ladder than
the first few rungs.
There is already a
self-sufficient knowledge that
they can acquire.
The arts of--to him the arts of
poetry that's the lowest rung
and yet that is its own self
sufficiency and then you can go
up the ladder and really learn
more--
but the interesting thing about
the ladder is that there is no
sense,
though it establishes a
hierarchy, in that hierarchy the
lower elements are as crucial as
the higher elements,
because without the lower rungs
you never really can go up to
the end.
So this is another image then
of the--
finally let me just say with
the Joachim,
the inclusion of Joachim,
here we are getting into the
erasure of strict barriers,
strict boundaries between what
is heretical and what is
canonical.
I think this is the sort of
openness,
Dante's openness that somehow
reverberates with the lesson of
Francis and Dominic,
and therefore now,
let me turn to those two
cantos.
Keep in mind then as we read
Canto XI,
we are again--I repeat in the
Heaven of the Sun and I don't
know that the passage that I
read to you from the pseudo
Dionysus last time about the
divine names where the pseudo
Dionysus goes on talking about
why is the metaphor of the sun
such a fundamental image for the
divine generosity.
This is as an image of the sun
that always gives of itself
without ever asking anything
back so it's an activity of
purely--
pure generosity and I think
that's a Franciscan image of--
also of poverty to which I will
talk about in a moment.
The Canto XI,
I repeat, ends with the
extraordinary encomium of Siger
of Brabant;
by a counterpoint Canto XI has
an apostrophe against logical,
legal forms of knowledge.
The kind of knowledge that
tries to define the world in
formulas and so Dante begins--
this is Dante speaking on his
own--in his own voice,
"Oh insensate care of
mortals,
how vain are the reasonings
that make thee beat thy wings in
downward flight!
One was going after law,
another after the
Aphorisms,
one following the priesthood
and another seeking to rule by
force or craft,
one set on robbery and another
on affairs of state,
one labouring in the toils of
fleshly delights,
and another given up to
idleness;
while I, set free from all
these things,
was high in heaven with
Beatrice, received thus
gloriously."
I think it's an interesting
counterpoint between these icons
of power that derive from the
study of low and logic,
and then on the other hand,
this--Dante's own self
reference to himself as free
from all of these concerns.
I think this idea of freedom
will be the dominant theme of
Canto XI.
Who--it continues then,
"When each had come back
to the point of the circle where
it was before,"
the two wheels of dancing old
men,
holding their hands around the
sun,
which is a metaphorical sun--so
that the universe is not even--
is not heliocentric.
Dante's universe--they're going
to move now beyond the sun,
"is stopped like a candle
on its stand."
And then there is a little
prayer here and the introduction
of the two,
Dominic and Francis,
lines 30 and following:
"The Providence that rules
the world with that counsel in
which every created site is
vanquished before it reaches the
bottom- in order that the bride
of Him who,
with loud cries,
wedded her with His sacred
blood should go to her Beloved
secure in herself and
faithfuller to Him- ordained for
her behoof two princes to be her
guides on this side and that.
The one was all seraphic in
ardour,"
and that's Francis,
"the other, for wisdom,
was on earth a splendour of
cherubic light.
I shall tell of the one,
since to praise one,
whichever we take,
is to speak of both;
for the labours where to one
end."
That's really the formula that
seals the sense of the
interdependence of intellect and
will of love and knowledge and
of the two voices.
Now this is the--what we call a
hagiography or a legend,
the life of a saint,
a saint's life of Francis,
which is told by Aquinas,
by the Dominican Aquinas.
What we are told is,
first of all--"Between the
Topino and the water that falls
from the hill chosen by the
blessed Ubaldo hangs a fertile
slope of the lofty mountain from
which Perugia feels cold and
heat at Porta Sole,
and behind it Nocera and Gualdo
grieve under a heavy yoke."
It's an extraordinarily
localized representation of
Francis' origin.
It's a topography,
he was born as you know in
Assisi,
but it's almost as if he were
just placing him in a specific
place,
near the gate that leads--on
the road to Perugia;
very precise and it's called
Porta Sole, more about this in a
moment.
"From this slope,
where it most breaks its
steepness,
a sun,"
now we go from the toponymic,
the name of a place,
the gate of the sun-- -to a
metaphor for Francis as the sun.
He is the sun,
so we are in the Heaven of the
Sun and now Dante invests
Francis with all the attributes
of this solarity,
this continuous,
steady giving of oneself as the
sun does in the Neo-platonic
imagery,
the mystical neo-Platonic
imagery of the pseudo Dionysus.
A sun rose on the world as this
does sometimes from the Ganges.
As soon as we--Dante has
mentioned the specific place for
Francis' birth,
then the coordinates of--the
geographic coordinates
completely change.
We go from the specific and
local to literally the global,
the world of the Ganges,
the Orient, something a little
vaster.
As if the sun,
Francis really acts between the
concrete and local,
and the widest possible
reference.
"Therefore let him who
makes mention of that place not
say Ascesi,"
which means I rise,
but it's punning with Assisi,
"for he would say too
little,
but Orient, if he would
name it rightly."
It's an extraordinary image and
two astronomical terms,
the sun and the Orient for
Francis.
Francis appears as--not just as
the sun does,
as one who can--and I'm playing
with the text here a little bit
but not much--
one who orients us,
one who is supposed to orient
and re-orient us is born in
Assisi and yet disappears as if
it were the East.
What were his--What Dante is
implying,
I think, is that for those who
go on the face of the earth and
lose their ways then Francis
becomes one who can tell them
how to find their way back
wherever they are going.
For those who do not know their
way at all, have never known the
way, they are capable of
discovering it.
He is providing this light,
so what is this light that he
provides?
What kind of light does he
bring out?
"He was not yet far from
his rising,"
the metaphorics of the sun
continues,
"when he began to make the
earth feel some strengthening
from his mighty influence;
for," and now he gives the
story of Francis' life.
Before I go there I just want
to tell you that Dante--
and I brought a translation of
a poem that Dante knew that
Francis is an extraordinary-- is
a great poet.
He's actually--we consider him
the first poet in Italian,
in the Italian language.
I Just want to read a few
stanzas from the so called
Canticle of Brother Sun
so that you can see how Dante's
own metaphorics derive straight
out of this Franciscan vision,
Franciscan spirituality.
He begins, "Most
high," it's a prayer,
a Canticle of Brother
Sun, "all powerful good
Lord!
Yours are the praises,
the glory, the honor,
and all blessing.
To you alone most high do they
belong, and no man is worthy to
mention your name.
Praise be you my Lord with all
your creatures,
especially Brother Sun who is
the day and through whom you
give us light,
and it's beautiful and radiant
with great splendor and bears a
likeness of you most High One.
Praise be you my Lord through
Sister Moon and the stars.
In heaven you formed them clear
and precious and beautiful,
praised be you my Lord through
Brother Wind."
He goes through all the four
elements and part of the
suggestiveness of this poem is
that it's a song of praise to
God,
clearly enough,
but it is also--we never know
if Francis is thinking of these
elements: the sun,
the moon, the wind,
the water, death itself--
as the medium through whom he
can praise,
or the cause on account of
which he should praise,
or the other agents;
the Italian is very ambiguous.
"Por,"
for those of you who may know a
little French or a little
Spanish,
for, by, through,
this is--so there's a kind of
extraordinarily choir and
orchestration.
The other thing that I should
mention is that finally we can
understand the rhetoric of
praise that is running through
this poem,
but we also saw as describing
the rhetoric of praise in
Dante's Vita nuova when
he finds out that the best way
of writing about Beatrice is
really to write praise poems,
not actually--which he
distinguishes from flattery but
praise poems,
the poems of praise means in
many ways rejecting all sense of
ownership.
Realizing that not--the fact
that one may know,
the world doesn't mean that one
owns it and also it means that
not knowing Beatrice is not just
a cover to wish to own her,
so the praise is as
disinterested and as free a mode
of acknowledgement of Beatrice
herself.
Let's see how this continues,
this whole poetic vision of
Francis continues with Canto XI.
Dante goes on giving us the
life of Francis and he catches
Francis in what is--
in what I would call using the
language of anthropology really,
a liminal stage.
You know what I mean by the
liminal stage?
The world liminal comes
from--it's the Latin threshold
or comes from the Latin for
limit,
there are two words,
in many ways very
contradictory,
but it has the power liman is
one thing meaning threshold,
but also the word might also be
limit,
so the threshold may be a limit
and the threshold may also be an
opportunity to cross,
a way of going over.
I call it--Dante doesn't use
here;
he does use the word limit
several times,
not in this context.
Dante places Francis in a
liminal position that is to say,
between and betweest two
different orders.
On the one hand the world,
and on the other hand,
some kind of utopian idea that
we never--
which would be the order that
he goes on to institute or some
general vision about what the
world ought to be.
He places Francis in between
neither part of the world,
nor part of this final utopia
and let's see what he does in
this liminal position.
That's where he catches him and
look at these lines here,
"Still a youth,"
this is the biography of
Francis modeled on a number of
biographies that existed at the
time.
"For still a youth he ran
into strife with his father,
for a lady to whom as to death
not willingly unlocks the
door," which is an
extraordinarily difficult line
to translate.
The Italian really could be
read to say unlocks the door of
pleasure.
"And before his spiritual
court," and now he uses a
Latin phrase,
which is a legal formula and
has the value of a legal
formula,
coram patre,
that is to say he marries this
woman,
we don't know who she is yet,
in the presence of his own
father,
thus giving legitimacy to his
act, the act of marriage.
"Coram patre he was
joined to her and thenceforth
loved her better every day.
She, bereft of her first
husband,"
Christ,
"despised and obscure
eleven hundred years and more,
remained without a suitor till
he came;
nor did it avail when men heard
that he who put all the world in
fear found her unmoved,
with Amyclas,
at the sound of his voice;
nor did it avail her to have
such courage and constancy that,
where Mary stayed below,
she mounted on the cross with
Christ.
But, lest I proceed too darkly,
take now Francis and Poverty
for these lovers in all I have
said.
Their harmony and happy looks
moved men to love and wonder and
sweet contemplation and led them
to holy thoughts,
so that the venerable Bernard
first went barefoot and ran
after that great peace and,
running, thought himself too
slow.
Oh wealth unknown and fruitful
good!"
There is clearly a reversal,
Francis marries poverty,
and yet to have that marriage
of Poverty we have to understand
what--in a moment what that is.
A lot of wealth,
a lot of riches can be
produced, a clear turning of
whatever intentions he may have
had and the consequences of that
act of his.
What is this representation of
Francis?
It's, I think,
in this liminal position,
Francis is shown as he is
turning upside down all the
values that the world holds
dear.
He wants to marry nothing.
Poverty, to marry Poverty is to
marry nothing.
You marry to be--you want
to--you yoked yourself,
you embrace owning nothing,
but that marriage or that union
appears as a sacramental act so
he is making fun,
he is parodying marriage.
Just let me be a bit
more--because I don't want to
imply at all any blasphemy here,
but he's parodying even the
sacrament of marriage,
he is marrying nothing.
It's not a legal person,
some age in Poverty,
it's just an idealization or an
allegory for nothing,
but that is conducted,
that ceremony,
is conducted as if it were a
sacramental act.
Not only a sacramental act,
he's parodying the law,
because he's marrying Poverty
in the presence of his own
father.
He undress--he divests himself
of all the clothes,
which in the Middle Ages,
as much as now,
always stands for some form of
symbolic status.
The way you dress according to
the job you want,
they usually say,
right?
That is to say--what I mean to
say is that dresses,
clothes are part of a social
set of values which Francis is
flouting and parodying.
We have--we are in the presence
of the parody of legal language,
sacramental language,
even the language of love.
At one point,
the language of sexuality,
the idea of marrying Poverty
to--does not--
I changed the translation of
the phrase the way Sinclair,
because it's a little bit
torturous even in Italian,
the way Sinclair has it--he
says "none willingly
unlocks the door,"
that unwillingly is the door of
pleasure.
Even sexuality,
which is certainly a value of
the world, Francis will turn
around.
This is a radical critique of
the value system of the world.
Call it a prophetic mode of
abandoning the idols of the
world in favor of some kind of
utopia or unexpected or really
not clarified,
not very well described vision
of how the world ought to be,
but this is--he rejects all of
this so "She,
bereft of her first
husband"--
"coram patre he was
joined to her,
and thenceforth loved her
better every day.
She, bereft of her first
husband, despised and obscure
eleven hundred years and more,
remained without a suitor till
he came;
nor did it avail when men heard
that he who put all the world in
fear found her unmoved,
with Amyclas,
at the sound of his voice;
nor did it avail her to have
such courage and constancy that,
where Mary stayed below,
she," Poverty,
"mounted on the cross with
Christ."
She does something even better
than what Mary does,
"But lest I proceed too
darkly,
take now Francis and Poverty
for these lovers in all I have
said."
"Their harmony and happy
looks," this is another
parody of the language of the
amorous discourse of medieval
love poetry.
They go on--he just--it's a
dalliance with nothing,
so they have now finally an
inclusion of an extraordinary
non-value because that's what
poverty is,
something that questions all
values and it's a Franciscan
idea of poverty.
What do they mean by that?
What did Francis mean by this,
by this idea of poverty,
what is this poverty?
First of all,
you know that this subject
became part of an extensive
iconographic representation.
One can think of the Giotto
frescos, the cycles of,
Franciscan cycles in Assisi,
but all over Tuscany and
Umbria.
It's not only unique to Dante's
understanding,
and Dante's insight,
it's a sort of representation
and fascination with Francis.
Another little detail that I
should tell you is that Francis,
in Italian, is Franciscos,
meaning that he is French,
and there was the--like
Francesca, the other Francesca,
the other one who also
understood a lot about love,
but lost her way in Canto V.
It really means free,
the word in English,
you have the word
"frank"
which in many ways carries over
the resonance of the Latin word
Franciscos.
Francis, true to his name,
is now as being poor is
absolutely free,
there's no bondage to anything.
There's nothing that holds him
to anything in the world,
so this is one important,
let's call it ethical extension
of poverty.
What did they mean?
What did the other Franciscans,
like Bonaventure,
who was there listening to what
Aquinas may say about the
founder of his order,
what did they understand by
that?
Remember we talked about--Dante
certainly seems to have stressed
the idea of poverty being
poverty in a very material
bodily way, corporeal,
physical.
In this sense,
I call it prophetic in the
sense that,
as you know,
what distinguishes the biblical
prophets from other prophets is
that they usually choose to bear
on their flesh the signs that
they utter against the world.
If they want to speak about
this infidelity of Israel they
would marry a prostitute.
If they want to denounce the
dissidence,
heresies, and lacerations
within the body politic of
Israel they would even go on
cutting off an arm of theirs to
dramatize on the flesh this idea
of--
these prophetic pronouncements
that we're making.
This is part of what Francis
then is doing here,
and this idea that he's
living--Poverty it's not just an
allegory as an allegorical
representation,
it is something lived in the
flesh;
the literal and the allegorical
are now compressed,
but there's more,
what did--what does,
for instance,
Bonaventure think of what
poverty is?
Dante, I repeat,
thinks about the material idea
of poverty,
so a way of opposing avarice,
a way of opposing prodigality,
attachment or contempt for the
values.
We have seen all of that
before, but poverty to them also
means poverty of language.
Francis, the first one to--I've
articulated, even that poem of
his;
repetitive, the same simple
formulaic expressions,
praise be omnipotent it said,
Oh Lord it said,
repeated, it's a poverty of
language,
the poverty of our thoughts,
that which Dante at the
beginning of Canto XI has been
calling the
"defective."
Remember that is the word that
I did not stress when we were,
"insensate care of
mortals, how vain are the
reasonings."
How "defective"
the Italian original says how
"defective,"
I hope some translators pick up
"defective"
and make it and say that it's
in the idea that they are
lacking,
that they have nothing of their
own,
so that retrospectively you can
understand what I'm talking
about that we cannot own the
world,
that this--the world is a world
of gifts that the economies--
an economy of giving,
constant giving,
because the more you give and
the less you have of yourself,
the more you are free and the
more productive your own acts
can become as were the case of
Francis.
This is not all that Dante will
do with Francis this is
now--there is one little
reference that I want to
mention.
This is around lines 102 or so,
Francis will go on trying to
have this--
to receive a seal of approval
from the popes about the
fraternity,
the order, the confraternity,
whatever--
that he organized "When
the company of Poor Brothers
increased behind him whose
wondrous life were better sung
in heaven's glory,
the holy purpose of this chief
shepherd was encircled with a
second crown by the Eternal
Spirit through Honorius."
Honorius agrees--the Pope
Honorius agrees to recognize
this new order.
Now listen to this,
that's really the point that I
want to stop on for a while.
"And when in thirst for
martyrdom,
he had preached Christ and them
that followed Him in the proud
presence of the Sultan,
and, finding the people unripe
for conversion and not being
willing to remain for no
purpose,
he had returned to the harvest
of the Italian fields,
then, on the rough crag between
Tiber and Arno,
he received from Christ the
last seal,
which his members bore for two
years."
He's alluding to the famous
story of the stigmata that
Francis received;
the body becomes a sign.
What I was trying to explain
with the reference to the Hebrew
prophets who dramatize their--
and legitimize the validity of
the message by an inscription of
that message on the literal--
the physicality of their own
flesh and it's-- let's leave at
that.
The point though,
that Dante is making,
this is the story of the
stigmata, but it's also the
story of Francis who tries to go
and preach to the Sultan.
He fails on having the
theological argument and the
two--the Sultan and Francis
depart, each along his way--on
his way and that's it.
It's a story of--that can be
understood apparently as a
failure of Francis' message.
At the same time,
it is an extraordinary
hermeneutical term that has
taken place in Dante's thinking.
We have had,
and we will have,
celebrations of the crusades.
Now we have a story of an
encounter between Christians and
Muslims in terms of peaceful
language,
peaceful speech,
where the two exponents,
or--two of the exponents of the
particular beliefs can come
together and encounter,
and they can discuss.
The Sultan says no,
for him we are not ripe,
and for--the Sultan probably
says, well I don't think you
know what you are talking about
and they leave.
This is an extraordinary change
in the dissemination of violence
that had been at the center of
so much theological discourse
and here Dante seems to be
opting and following Francis on
a different route.
This is, I think,
an important change in the
consciousness,
the historic understanding of
the relationship between
Christians and Muslims and their
interpretations of the crusade.
There is a further detail that
I want to mention here.
The detail is this detail about
two geographic coordinates in
this canto.
Now we have just read about
Francis' trip to Egypt and the
Sultan.
A little earlier Dante gives
the--refers to the birthplace of
Francis by talking about the
Ganges.
In other words Dante has--is
aware that there is a European
world that we talked about last
time, but there are two other
coordinates.
One, a Hindu world of the
Ganges and we shall see what the
means for him,
and the other one is the Muslim
world of the Sultan.
He's acknowledging in many ways
that which is--we probably may
not be entirely familiar with
this problem.
He's acknowledging that which
the--someone like Bonaventure
had been discussing.
In 1273, Bonaventure,
the man that we shall see in
the next canto,
traveled to Paris to give a
number of lectures at the
University of Paris,
he will die a year later in
1274, and they are called
Conferences.
A number of conferences in
which he just debates the
question of the relationship
between what he calls these
three cultures:
Hindu,
the Christian,
and the Muslim,
and tries to see in what way
they can be harmonized.
He connects,
it's Bonaventure,
connects the Hindu religion
with joachism,
in the sense that the Joachim
of the third age,
not complicated at all,
you remember that Joachim has
this paradigm of history
according to a tripartite
structure: the age of the
Father, the Son,
and the Spirit.
The third age,
which is his own age,
the age when Bonaventure lives,
when Dante lives,
is the age of the Spirit
implies the elimination of all
institutions.
The idea that the Spirit now is
everywhere and there is no need
for any hierarchy or any order.
Bonaventure says this is
exactly the world of the Hindus
who believe that God is
everywhere,
and then he goes on talking
about he,
Bonaventure,
talks about the Muslims for
whose theologies are a theology
of an impassable distance
between God--
a transcendence that nothing
can really bridge between a God
who remains invisible and the
world of every man here.
Of course for him,
the mediation between the two
is given by Christianity because
with the idea of--
there is a transcendence and at
the same time an imminence of
God in the transcendence of God.
Dante is, I think,
echoing this text and these
problems in the canto of
Francis,
so he places Francis between
the Ganges and Egypt,
and places him as the one who
is carving a new space,
the space that he calls that of
poverty meaning freedom,
meaning the will,
meaning the way of love as a
way of coming to the knowledge
of God.
Then I would like to move on
to, very briefly,
to Canto XII.
Briefly, not because I am
not--I'm insensitive to what
Dante will do with Dominic in
Canto XII,
we really haven't got time,
but I want to mention to you a
number of things.
How the encounter with
Bonaventure--I'm sorry the
encounter with the description
of Dominic told by Bonaventure
really rewrites the previous
canto.
There, in the previous canto of
Francis where the marriage,
parodic, kind of anarchic idea
of the valuelessness of all the
worldly values.
Here now, we have a different
wedding, a different marriage
between Dominic and faith;
between knowledge and theology
if you want to put it at a very
generic and general level.
Here too, there is the--let me
just go over with lines 45,
"In that part,"
that's the description of the
legend of Dominic,
the life of Dominic,
"In that part where sweet
Zephyr rises to open the new
leaves in which Europe,"
once again see how Dante's--
there is a kind of continental
imagination here,
the Asia, Africa,
and Europe, the three
continents "in which Europe
sees herself reclad,
not far from the beating of the
waves behind which the sun,
after his long flight,
sometimes hides himself from
all men,
lies favoured Calahorra."
You'll love this detail;
I know that--I can tell by the
way the eyes of some of you
smile when I point this thing.
Dante is talking about the
birthplace of Dominic and places
that--which is where it was,
in the western part of Spain,
there were the sun sets.
Dominic becomes the counter to
Francis;
he was born where the sun rises
and now Dominic is within where
the sun sets.
So between the two of them the
whole movement of the sun,
the translatio,
the translation of faith,
not the translation of empires,
not the translation of culture,
the translation of faith seems
to be encompassed between the
two of them.
That which will make you smile
is that Dante mentions,
and you can check,
Francis' birth in the East
where the sun rises at line 50
of Canto XI,
and he mentions the setting sun
of Dominic in line 52 of Canto
XII,
as if there is a kind of--this
is a kind of little touch,
I think it's--I find it a very
amusing touch between them.
To account for the difference
in proximity between the two,
as if this movement also has a
kind of--
the movement of the sun from
east to west on account of them
has its own quickness,
its own rhythm.
"In it was born the loving
liegeman of the Christian faith,
the holy athlete,
gracious to his own and
pitiless to enemies;
and his mind,
as soon as it was created,
was so full of living power
that in his mother's womb it
made her prophetic.
When the espousals between him
and the faith were completed at
the holy font,"
here there is another marriage
ceremony that counters the
previous marriage ceremony of
Canto XI.
I want to draw your attention
to the use of these playful
images, the athletes of faith,
the liegemen.
In the previous canto,
we had Francis,
who I said, parodies all the
values of the world.
He is called--and that has
really become a formula to
describe both Francis--
unless Dominic though,
they are the so-called--
I'll give it to you in Latin
and translate it.
In English we would call them
the "clowns of the
lord,"
lociulatories;
they are the clowns,
lociulatories domini.
The "clowns of the
Lord," that is to say they
are playing, they are playing at
the world;
they play with the world.
They bring in what we would
call a perspective of play in
the world.
They are making fun of the
world, they are challenging the
values of the world and in this
sense they bring out that which
becomes the most impressive
aspect of their theology,
which is that of a playful
theology.
We'll talk more about this.
The notion that God plays,
that creation itself is a
spectacle,
I call it a
"theodrama,"
the idea that God is not--
it doesn't deprive the Divinity
of its seriousness but makes
that seriousness part of the
world of joy.
That's the whole--the
aesthetics, the new aesthetics
that Francis manages to release,
and Dominic manages also to
release,
this kind of playful idea of
the world, a comedy.
I tried to explain to you from
the very first day when we got
together how complicated it was
for me,
at the time,
to explain why Dante calls his
text a comedy because this is so
sublime.
It seems to be--he's talking
about how the ordinary and plain
man of the year,
around the year 1300,
manages to have the most
sublime of experiences.
And this idea--of course this
is about the happy ending
because comedies are always the
genre of happy endings.
It is about the low level of
experiences,
about the vulgar language that
Dante uses,
but the real and substantial
reason for Dante calling his
poem a comedy,
and for the readers using the
attribute of divine,
was exactly--is exactly that;
a way of responding to this
sense of the joyful quality of
creation, that's the point.
For all the seriousness--for
all the horror that we have been
witnessing through Hell and
Purgatory,
joy seems to be,
that we're told which Dante is
moving.
Not a tragic vision because
once you play of--
once you think of play you can
no longer have the tragic vision
because you understand that the
tragic vision is part of
something larger.
It is part--it is vicissitudes,
comedies,
and tragedies,
elegies are all linked to the
wheel of fortune in medieval
iconography,
so you keep going around but
they're all part of something
really larger,
which is this playful theology,
this theologia ludic
that he has been encompassing,
that he has been preparing for
us.
Let me just go on with a few
more details here,
a couple of minutes and
then--this relationship now of--
the other issue that really and
retrospectively,
the other issue that Dante is
raising,
let me just talk about this.
In the canto of Dominic,
much more than he did in the
canto of Francis,
this is really a unique moment.
It is a representation in terms
of language.
It is as if whatever orthodoxy
Dominic stands for,
because that's why the
Dominicans--the Dominicans were
the intellectual arm of the
Church;
they were, as I said,
founded with a specific purpose
of entering the universities and
debating the various points of
view.
They were the Aristotelians,
they were the poets,
they were traditionally the
troublemakers of--they were the
figures, the philosophers and so
on;
especially in Paris,
that's the university.
There was a--there is an idea
of orthodoxy with Dominic and
yet, here the whole
representation takes place in
terms of language.
Let me give you a couple of
examples around lines 80,
"Many a time his nurse
found him silent and awake on
the ground,"
this is part of this
lodatio,
this encomium now of Dominic,
"as if he said 'For this
am I come'.
O father of him,
Felice,"
Felix, "indeed!
O mother of him,
Giovanna indeed,
if, interpreted,
it means what they say!"
Dante is playing with
etymologies here,
the father is really happy;
there is a relationship between
the name and his state of mind.
And the mother is,
meaning the one who is full of
grace Giovanna,
the one who comes before is
also, if you interpret it
properly.
That is to say,
orthodoxy or heresy,
being its flip side,
right?
Heresy and orthodoxy;
we could have been talking
about Siger of Brabant's heresy,
we've been talking about
Joachim's heresy,
here appears as a question of
language,
as a question of an order that
is above all a grammatical
order,
and therefore,
it means a kind of correction
or has a kind of ambiguity that
you always assume,
and you always presume,
to be present within the order
of language.
Anything, in fact
retrospectively I can say to
you,
that even the schisms of
Inferno, where we saw the
poet Bertrand de Born,
you remember that horrifying
picture of the poet who holds in
his own hand like a lamp his own
head and goes on talking to
Virgil and Dante.
Or, in that same canto,
there was the presence of
Mohammed whose body seemed to be
completely lacerated.
Even the schisms are questions
of language, are
questions--Dante understands
them as issues of language.
Which does not--which only
means this,
to talk about language,
I repeat, they are part of the
imponderable quality of
language,
the ambiguities of language,
the force of language,
and the power of language.
That's what I can tell you
about these cantos;
and let me stop here and see if
there are questions that I would
most gladly hear,
if not answer but--please.
Student:  Would Dante
have faced any threat from the
Church for placing Joachim in
Paradise as someone who--
Prof: The question is
would Dante have faced some
censorship,
probably, from the Church
authorities for placing Joachim
in Paradise?
Actually no,
not at all, because the formula
he uses--
here comes the Calabrian Abbot
Joachim endowed with the gift of
prophecy more or less,
that's the translation.
It translates a Latin formula,
the spiritu
prophetico totato,
which was already used.
He had been--Joachim had
already been exempted of the
censure of his thoughts that
Bonaventure had voiced,
and in the mass,
in honor of Joachim they would
use that formula.
So he's actually using a
canonical formula,
a church formula for his own,
for Joachim's own--
never happened,
he's not a saint,
never was a saint,
but what Dante probably--that's
what he did is he should be
canonized.
No, but the answer is--;and
that's the reason why he could
not have faced any reprimands.
Yes.
Student:  You were
talking about--with St.
Francis and sort of how Poverty
and St.
Francis as a form of freedom.
When he weds freedom he's--or
sorry,
when he weds Poverty he becomes
more free,
can we link that to--or how can
we link that,
is my question,
to Dante's--his own poverty and
exile;
is that meant to be linked?
Are we supposed to be thinking
about Dante having to depend on,
I guess, the charity of others?
Prof: Good question,
the question is,
I was talking about Poverty as
being a state of freedom in the
canto of Francis.
Are we supposed to also
associate Dante's own fate of
poor, exile, beggar that he was
during his exile in that
description.
That's the question.
I would say yes,
of course, the--Poverty I hope
I explained means several things
for Dante.
Bonaventure will go on thinking
about poverty of language,
poverty of philosophy,
etc., but all of them
understand poverty in a very
literal way,
but all of them understand one
thing that this kind of poverty
is really a description of the
human condition to begin with.
We are all poor,
that's the primary sense.
We are all born defective and
in need,
whatever needs were,
some of us go on being needy,
and we are, all our lives,
so this is a general
understanding of the idea of
poverty.
Then there is a sort of--the
other side of this,
and the other side is that it's
actually a blessing because it's
the state of freedom.
If this is really very much
like what you expect to the
philosophical freedom,
you know, without any cares.
Even Horace--I don't want to
have wealth and it's not
worrying about having the cares
about how the stock market is
doing today or not doing,
so I want to be completely free
of that and it's a state of
freedom.
Is Dante also thinking about
himself?
Does it have a consolatory note
for him to believe that after
all I'm not alone?
Yes, I would say that that's
the case.
In his own life Dante,
unlike Petrarch who really
died--
a poet who follows a few years
after Dante,
he really died one of the
wealthiest men of his time by
virtue of being a poet,
a writer, and so on,
Dante never got to that point.
Student:  I mean,
I'm wondering if we should take
it literally as sort of feelings
about Poverty or is it more like
an idea like a sort of poetic
escape into a perspective I
guess that he had gotten in the
perspective of Poverty.
Prof: Should we take it
literally or just as a poetic
way of speaking?
I think that I answered that by
saying--but I think you're
asking something else maybe,
and then I'll get to that since
you are.
I think I'm saying that this
was really the reality of his
life.
A stand such as that is bound
to appear maybe,
well, you know,
you need a little bit of
comfort and consolation,
and so you say it's a poverty
but it really has the chrism of
Francis' spirituality.
I'm not trying to diminish
Dante's convictions.
What I think you're really
asking is,
I don't know you're really
asking, I don't know,
but I know what you are
asking--but there is another
side to your question.
Are you asking me whether or
not he was a Franciscan,
for instance,
is that what you're asking?
Because if you are that would
be a very good question in the
sense that there were a lot of
ideas.
We don't have any evidence,
but a lot of ideas that he
became a member of the third
order of the Franciscans,
a lay order of the Franciscans,
so that he practiced therefore,
truly, literally in his own
life, that which Francis himself
had practiced and preached so
maybe that's what--
probably if you weren't asking
that maybe you should have been
asking that and I would have
been--
I would have said that.
Other questions or--we have a
few minutes so--yes.
Student:  Is the story
of the Sultan--
supposed to revise our view of
Dante's relation--
Dante's view of Islam that we
took away from the
Inferno,
from the encounter with
Mohammad.
Prof: That's a very good
question.
Is the view of Francis going to
the Sultan supposed--
is it meant to revise the view
that we may have formed of
Dante's attitude toward Islam
reading Inferno XXVIII?
I think so.
My answer is that I--that's why
I was stressing this,
that there is a sort of a
radical turning that takes place
in Francis,
operates a change in the way
that Christians and the Muslims
can go on thinking of their
encounter.
It's no longer through armies,
if it's through peaceful
discourse.
From this point of view,
Francis carries on a tradition
that started with Peter the
Venerable,
there were a few other
theologians who had a kind of
view that was not through wars
that this kind of dialogue could
take place,
if war is a form of dialogue,
I'm not sure of course.
Dante acknowledges that in
Francis,
and I think that he dramatizes
it, just as he is dramatizing
the sense of the awareness,
which was very central to
Bonaventure,
of the relationship of the
three, to him,
the three religions:
the Hindus, the Christians,
and the Muslims.
And retrospectively,
it forced me to now say things
about schism that I did not say
when we were reading Canto
XXVIII,
that schism--we have a presence
there of,
you remember,
all forms of schism;
the religious schism with a
friar who decides who is really
a joachist, by the way,
Dolcino.
There was the poet who,
by the power of his words,
Bertrand de Born,
the Provencal poet divides
father from son,
the king from the son,
and therefore breaks the unity
of the body politic,
the idea that the king's two
bodies and the famous formula of
the book of the great historian
>
so that he broke that kind of
unity.
There is then an allusion to a
story from Lucan,
one of the soldiers Curio,
who broke away from Pompeii and
he had,
from Caesar,
and he had his own tongue cut
off.
It's clear that schism is to be
understood linguistically.
I am not revising my view but
now I can tell you what I always
thought was underlying the
representation of even Islam,
which means that even the
interpretation of Mohammed in
XXVIII,
horrifying though as it is,
it really appears as if
Mohammed was the one who was
doubling the existing unity--
that's it, through the power of
speech,
that's the view.
It's a horrifying
representation,
that does not take anything
away from that,
but clearly you see that
the--Dante's understanding of
these issues is a little bit
more nuanced than it may at
first sight appear.
When we come later in the
Heaven of Justice,
and before we get to Heaven of
Justice,
Dante goes on talking about the
warriors and he begins with
Joshua,
the hero who brings about the
destruction of Jericho etc.
By the end he also mentions the
crusaders, so there is a kind of
ambiguity that I would say that
he still values what he thinks
is the heroic life.
Nonetheless,
after I say this,
let me just state another point
about Dante.
That's true,
that clearly he's talking from
a Christina standpoint,
there's no question about this.
But the underlying spirituality
of Dante is what I call the
"spirituality of the
desert."
Dante's truly the "poet of
the desert"
in the sense that in the desert
you have modes of a quest that
where everyone is really going,
because wherever we are going,
we are always going to the
absolute.
Whatever journey we may take
it's always the same journey and
so the spirituality of the quest
is sort of--
I won't say overhauls,
but at least tempers this idea
of Dante being so strict and
firm in this universe of degrees
and distinctions that he sets
up.
I don't know if I clarified
this for you,
okay.
Thank you so much.